let's go to let's go to our caller from
the 807 area code who's calling today
from 8:07 hi David my name is Clint I'm
calling from Canada
hey Clint what's up um I just want to
get your thoughts of today's situations
and I find that a lot of like America is
quite paranoid paranoid of what like
well well for just any kind of situation
that's happening in the current states
right now like say the coronavirus where
you have like and I know that you've you
have debated with Jesse Lee Peterson and
I do listen to them just because it's
like you know it's like a car wreck you
can walk away
um but and then you know that just the
rhetoric a lot of the right uses is it
just seems quite to be paranoid where he
uses terms as you know the immigrant
virus or you know like the legal alien
sickness and all that and same with like
steven crowder as well i just want to
get your thoughts on that
yeah this is not your observation is
accurate in that in the united states a
lot of right-wing political ideology is
motivated by fear of different kinds and
a warnings about violence infections
dirtiness immorality or whatever right
so there's a lot of you know an
anti-abortion based on the fear of going
to hell and that you're killing a person
if you go and get an abortion we need to
stop immigration because as Tucker
Carlson said immigrants will make our
country dirtier and poorer and they
bring disease and all sorts of stuff so
there's a lot a lot of that is
moralizing around cleanliness and
there's a lot of religious stuff that's
wrapped up in that that could be studied
and then also just generally fear monger
we need a strong president who's going
to be aggressive to other countries
because that's what will keep us safe
otherwise we'll get attacked it's a very
common theme of the how the right wing
operates yeah it's very
very commonly and just I've because I
work in the tourist industry up here and
we like most of our clientele us our
American interesting and a lot a lot of
like like don't get me wrong there's a
lot of good there's a lot of good ones
but then there you know you get those
you get those ones that are you can tell
like they're definitely right-wing yeah
and you it's it's like it's almost like
it almost turned into like just this
really paranoia of you know oh like it
and also like a lot of what-ifs like
what if this what if that wall you can
say that about anything right you know
like and I and I said and I notice
steven crowder uses that a lot and you
know and then these people have really
big followings and and sometimes I just
feel that the rhetoric is it is it is
quite dangerous
yep it's dangerous it's fear-based and
unfortunately it works on a lot of
people to a great degree
Clint from Canada thank you so much I
appreciate your call and I hope to hear
from you again in the future